hello and welcome to the spring 2012
edition of Rochford district matters the
information paper for the people of
Rochford district in this edition on our
articles on an award for 20 years of
neighborhood volunteering walking your
way to the Olympic Games a hat-trick for
the windmill council tax and the budget
for 2012-13 help for street parties and
much more but we'll start with some
important details about changes to your
recycling dates bin collections will
remain as normal on Good Friday the
sixth of April Easter Monday the ninth
of April May Day Monday the seventh of
may and the Spring Bank Holiday Monday
the fourth of June but the published
information regarding collections on the
diamond jubilee bank holiday on Tuesday
the fifth of jim has changed collections
will now not be going ahead on this day
Tuesday the fifth of June is the only
day during this week that collections
will not go ahead further information
will be made available near the time a
rayleigh couple who have dedicated 20
years to keeping their neighborhoods
safe have had their commitment
officially recognized Barbara and Tony
Oliver have been named winners of the
Essex neighborhood watch coordinator of
the Year award for 2011 the award which
is supported by essex police and the
Essex Police Authority recognizes the
important part co-ordinators play in
making Essex one of the safest places to
live and work the public and others
involved in community safety across the
county were invited to nominate
coordinators who have demonstrated
excellent service in their community
with more than 8,000 volunteer
coordinators neighborhood watch schemes
provide support and reassurance to over
a third of households across the whole
of Essex it's accepted that crime levels
reduce when there is an active scheme in
place
and there's less fear of crime when
people know what's going on in their
area and how to seek help and support
Mike Hooper chair of Rayleigh and
Rochford Neighborhood Watch said our
teams are very pleased that Rockford
district has won this award and welcome
all inquiries to their office regarding
setting up a neighbourhood watch scheme
on your street or road to build on this
success and further increase coverage in
the Rockford district you can contact
your local neighborhood watch or speak
to a member of your neighbourhood
policing team and find out more by
entering your postcode in the my
neighborhood section of the Essex Police
website at WWE sex police UK learning
computer skills the rayleigh Rochford
and district association for voluntary
service or rats as a wide range of
support an offer across the community in
the rotary district rats is once again
running their popular laptop courses
which aim to help over-50s learn
computing skills in a relaxed atmosphere
and laptop which stands for lifelong
access to pcs through training for older
people can help you with a Guinness
computer course home visits and a
computer club all in a relaxed
atmosphere among the skills the course
teaches are how to visit websites that
you have seen on television how to send
emails with photos detached how to
transfer photos from cameras to
computers and print them out and learn
about internet shopping so if you're
interested contact laptop at rat on 01
268 double 727 96 or email rafts and
that double our AVS a travel UK
the Citizens Advice service helps people
resolve their legal money and other
problems by providing free confidential
independent and impartial advice and
information and by influencing policy
makers helping prevent problems for
everyone if you live in the district and
would like to speak to a member of the
bureau the current opening hours for
initial assessments are at the rockford
office backplane Rochford SS 41 a why
Tuesdays and Thursdays ten a.m. to two
p.m. and at the rayleigh office in the
Civic sweet hockey road rayleigh SS 680
be monday thursday and friday from ten
a.m. to 2pm initial assessments are also
available via the telephone 08 double 44
double 70 80 80 or visit www k for
initial information on a variety of
aspects of daily living with the Olympic
Games coming to London later this year
rochford District Council has a massive
number of ways you can get involved in
the celebrations whether it's catching
sight of the Olympic torch coming
through rayleigh or taking part in the
SX urban games there's something for
everyone so get these dates in your
diary the centerpiece of the festivities
is the Olympic torch passing through
railing on a Friday the sixth of July
and a day of activities featuring street
entertainment on the high street and a
school sports competition on King George
the fifth playing fields the wind bill
will also be open next up is a
once-in-a-lifetime countrywide
celebration not to be missed sparks will
fly at wildwoods day on saturday the
second of june promises to be a
memorable experience featuring the very
best of local and national sporting
stars and artists in a unique event at
hollywood's sport and physical
activities will also play a central role
in the district's year-long celebrations
with opportunities for everyone to take
part in Olympic sports and try out
something new including the
sx urban games in September also in
September inspired by the London 2012
Cultural Olympiad our local artists are
at the heart of the 20 in 12 program
with olympic themed artist commissions
numerous art workshops and an
international theme to the rayleigh art
festival where we'll welcome arts and
culture from all over the world for more
details of these and other events
celebrating the games visit www k /o elv
and why not walk your way to the games
with us racewalking may be an event at
the London 2012 Olympic Games but you
don't need to be an athlete to walk your
way to a more active life the council is
taking part in a special project
organising a series of walks to help you
get healthy in the run-up to the London
2012 Olympic Games Rochford has teamed
up with the Essex legacy team at Essex
County Council along with
southend-on-sea Borough Council and
south east essex Ramblers to bring you
walking your way to the games the
challenge is simple there are five walks
to complete around South Essex each is
divided into five colours and you'll
receive a free gift for any walk that
you complete the challenge is can you
complete all five walks the red walk
which is the shortest is at Priory Park
it's a distance of between one and one
and a half miles it's on the
twenty-fifth of October it starts at 115
p.m. and the meeting point is outside
the cafe in priory park victoria avenue
southend-on-sea SS 26 and be the green
walk is a long can vc warm and that's a
distance between one and a half and one
of three quarter models it's on the
second of May and the 19th of September
the time is 1030am and the meeting point
is the lab with car park on Canvey SS 87
and cue the yellow walking hullbridge is
a distance of two
miles and it's on the twenty-third of
july at 1045 a.m. and the meeting point
is the car park the corner of ferry road
and pulls line in hullbridge SSR 56 PA
the blue walk in Hadley is a distance of
four miles and it's on the twentieth of
April and the seventh of September and
you meet at the Salvation Army car park
at 1030am the black walk which is the
longest at five miles is on the 13th of
june and the 15th of august and you meet
10am the castle in car park thus 181
little wakering Road SS 30 JW but please
know that all details are correct at the
time of printing but are subject to
change please check with event organiser
to confirm details and for more
information contact the Sports
Development Officer Mark alders on 0 1
702 31 8 121 or by email mark dot alders
and that's a LD o us at Rochford Garvey
UK
for the third year in a row the rayleigh
windmill has achieved the quality
assured visitor attraction accreditation
from visit england in their report visit
England the national body that assesses
visitor attractions throughout the
country praised the at warm welcome
offered by the volunteers as well as
their enthusiasm and knowledge you can
sample the same warm welcome that the
visit England judges enjoyed when the
windmill reopens for 2012 on Sunday the
first of april through to and including
sep tember the team that looks after the
windmill has put together a packed
programme of special events for you to
visit and enjoy throughout the year
among the exhibition's the windmill is
set to host are these Titanic the first
100 years first of april to the ninth of
May an exhibition by Rayleigh through
the looking glass featuring a range of
materials as well as the Titanic's links
with many Essex people and places sales
in the wind 12 have made the 27th of
June an exhibition presenting the
history of the windmill through film
oral history recordings and photos which
was created as part of a year-long
celebration of the windmills 200th
anniversary in 2009 Rochford district
celebrates in 2012 from the 30th of zoom
to the 12th of August this exhibition
celebrates London 2012 and the Olympic
torch passing through Rayleigh and
includes materials collected through
Rochford's dreams and memories Olympic
archive project the windmill opening
times are wednesdays from ten a.m. to
1pm and saturdays and sundays were 12 4
p.m. please check the website before
visiting as the windmill is sometimes
closed for private events the windmill
wouldn't be as successful or popular as
it is today without the support and
generosity of its volunteers and we're
always looking for more people to become
involved in the windmill for more
information on volunteering at the
windmill please contact the ledger
on 0 1 702 546 366 or email leisure at
Rochford dot-gov dot UK and the website
is www govt UK / windmill last year saw
the launch of the supporting talented
athletes in rochford or star at my local
scheme the scheme run by the council's
leisure team shop at my local and active
Rochford aims to help two of the
district's talented athletes to continue
to excel at the highest level businesses
that are part of shop at my local scheme
have the opportunity to support and
sponsor sailing champion Lucy Hodges and
Babington star Rebecca Terry so far 2012
pounds has been raised to support lucem
Rebecca and allow them to continue to
train and compete at the very highest
level the sponsors who have made this
possible are active Rochford Wells legal
homes and wells legal solicitors DB
training and sports therapy and
rehabilitation in 2011 star athlete Lucy
Hodges achieved a first place at the
blind nationals first place at the
multi-class regatta seventh of the world
blind match racing she says all this has
been helped by the Stars scheme I could
not have done all this without this help
the 2011 star athlete Rebecca Terry
achieved under 17 silver warwickshire
singles and doubles semifinals under-17
silver anglia runner-up in singles and
doubles under-17 silver sussex runner-up
in doubles under-17 gold essex singles
semifinals Middlesex senior bronze
semi-finals the under-17s 16 qualified
for national playoffs if you are
interested in the scheme contact Mark
orders on 0 1 702 318 one-to-one or
email mark Aldous at Rochford gov
okay and now for some details of three
100-pound prizes up for grabs the
revenues and benefits team is
responsible for producing printing and
posting thousands of council tax bills
and booklets every year we need your
help to reduce our costs and carbon
footprint we want you to sign up for
paperless billing and get your future
bills by email this is convenient for
you convenient for us and very good for
the environment as an incentive for
taking part in this campaign we're
offering you the chance to win one of
three 100-pound cash prizes to be in
with a chance of winning you must sign
up for paperless billing by 30th of
April 2012 by emailing your name and
council tax account number which is
found on your bill to paperless billing
at Rochford gov dropped UK and will do
the rest if we receive your email
request before five-thirty p.m. on the
thirtieth of April 2012 you will be
entered into our prize draw which will
take place on the first of May entry is
restricted to one request per household
winners will be notified by post the
following week and winner details will
be published in the summer issue of
Rochford district matters
the revenues and benefits team has
received nationally recognized
accreditation for its excellent customer
service for the second year running the
team retained its customer service
excellence award recognizing the way in
which they are continuously striving to
improve and develop their service in
response to the needs of their customers
following a rigorous assessment the team
demonstrated they are committed to
making sure customers who use their
services are provided with the
information they need quickly
professionally and courteously in
confirming the accreditation the
Assessor said they passed with flying
colors the team which is responsible for
administering housing and council tax
benefit as well as collecting council
tax business rates and investigating
benefit fraud it's just one of 21
revenues and benefits departments in the
country to have received the prestigious
accreditation Nick Scott manager of the
team said though we have received top
marks in this assessment we will
continue to raise our standards to
ensure our customers receive the service
they want and deserve did you know the
council has made claiming housing and
council tax benefit easier you can now
claim these benefits online by
completing an electronic claim form the
process is really quick and easy you
simply start with a calculator which
gives you an idea of the amount of
housing and council tax benefits you may
qualify for you then complete the claim
form which asks for the information we
need when you have finished you submit
the form and we receive it in our office
the same day you can print a copy for
your records with instructions about the
documents we need to see for more
information and to find the form visit
rochford claims dot and I'll spell the
next bit te-am n ET s.o.l com rochford
district councils council tax for the
financial year april 2012 to march 2013
has a game being frozen
essex county council and the Essex Fire
Authority have also frozen their parts
of the overall tax bill the Essex Police
Authority have set an increase of four
pounds fifty nine or three point four
seven percent and parish town councils
have increased by an average of two
pounds fifty two or seven point two
seven percent this means that the total
average council tax bill for a band d
property will be 1520 eight pounds 22
per annum an overall average increase of
seven pounds eleven pence per annum
which is point four seven percent of
your total council tax bill only
thirteen percent comes to Rochford
District Council with the rest going to
Essex County Council 71 percent Essex
County Fire and Rescue Authority four
percent Essex Police Authority nine
percent and the parish town councils
three percent for further information
see the booklet which accompanies your
council tax bill or visit our website
www Oxford garvey UK so how I Rochford
district council services funded the
council receives money from a government
grant including money towards the cost
of benefits paid out income from fees
and charges such as parking charges and
the money collected from council tax for
2012 13 the amounts are from the
government grant 26.8 million which
represents sixty-nine percent of the
total fees and charges 5.2 million
representing fourteen percent and
council tax 6.4 million representing
seventeen percent the local government
finance settlement was announced in
december 2011 this continues to reflect
the unprecedented economic circumstances
rochford District Council's grant was
reduced by 16.2 percent in 2011 and the
total grant awarded for 2012-13 is 3.2
49 million a further 11
one reduction to put this into
perspective delivery of statutory
services alone is estimated to cost
approximately nine point eight million
the budget gap for 2012-13 has been met
by reducing the budget for the cost of
the pest control service by 14,000
pounds increasing income by introducing
charges for parking at hockley woods and
freight house introducing a scheme of
charges for pre-application planning
advice ceasing to run the summer
swimming scheme producing a saving of
11,000 pounds in our corporate plan the
council identifies what it needs to
deliver for the whole district in line
with our priorities of making a
difference to our people community
environment and local economy for the
year ahead these include making a
difference to our people to continue to
deliver efficiency savings and
identifying opportunities for increasing
income including shared service working
and providing services to third parties
making a difference to our community to
respond to and implement the
requirements of the localism ACT to the
benefit of our community making a
difference to our environment by
implementing the action plan supports
the council's climate change and
sustainability strategy climate co2 de
making a difference to our local economy
to implement the joint area action plan
in partnership with Southend Borough
Council covering london Southend Airport
and its environs
your views played an important partner
decisions taken by councillors when they
looked at the budget for the next 12
months last year the council put
together a budget survey asking you to
prioritize council services in terms of
their importance and whether spending on
them should be reduced or increased the
survey was published in the last two
editions of Rochford district letters
and made available online on the
council's website prabhat of the survey
were also distributed at various council
meetings and venues in order to get as
many responses as possible in total 495
responses we received 328 by post and
167 online tackling anti-social behavior
an environmental Prime waste & Recycling
street cleaning and litter picking were
identified as the most important
services according to the responses the
areas where respondents re wanted to
reduce spending were sports culture and
leisure planning economic development
and parts and open spaces respondents
were split over some services for
example support to the community was
deemed a higher priority about 8.6
percent of respondents and a low
priority by 8.1 percent public and
environmental health was up a high
priority for 11.1 percent of respondents
and a low priority by six point seven
percent support to the voluntary sector
was a high priority for eight point
eight percent of respondents and nine
point nine percent thought it was a low
priority all age groups stated that
tackling anti-social behavior and
environmental crime was the highest
priority service as the services that
should see spending reductions the
under-25s and the 25 to 49 age groups
choice was planning economic development
while the 50 to 64 and 65 plus age
groups opted for sports culture and
leisure the feedback from this
consultation was considered by members
during the budget process if you
answered the budget survey or if you
want to help shape any full policy in
the future why not join our have your
say group
the group is made up of Rochford
residents who volunteered to express
their views on the council's proposals
and local services the information you
provide helps the council to make its
decisions in order for us to get the
information we need you will be asked to
fill in questionnaires and participate
in focus groups when signing up you will
be asked to highlight any particular
areas of interest to ensure your views
are taken into account when relevant
consultations come up you can sign up to
the group by visiting the website www k
/f your say you can call andrew lowing
community planning officer on 0170 2318
2061 or you can email him Andrew lowing
at Rochford Garf dot uk' out and about
details of what's happening in your area
markets hullbridge farmers market at
hullbridge community center Paul's Lane
is started on the twenty-fourth of March
and is held every fourth saturday of the
month between 9am and 1230pm entry and
parking free contact 0170 2230 374
hockley farmers market this is at the
old fire station 58 South End Road
hockley on the fourteenth of April
between 9am and 12 noon this market
sells bread and cakes eggs funny
cheese's organic vegetables chutneys and
jams home breed poultry and meats and
lots more contact inquiries at hotly
hyphen essex gov dot uk' really high
street market this is every wednesday
from eight a.m. to 2p n you can buy
fresh meat fish fruit vegetables
speciality breads cakes cheese pies
groceries household products jewelry
handbags sweets garden ornaments pet
food
and lots more besides taxi pickup is in
the lay-by at the crown pub and drop off
in the labor at the clock wallasey
wanders book now to take a wander around
the RSP B's stunning wallasey Island
project stroll along the seawall with
the wallasey birder and project
volunteers watch the landscape change
with the seasons and be inspired by the
sheer scale of the wild coast on your
doorstep the wonders are free of charge
but booking is essential for more
details contact Hilary on 0 1 702 258
357 or Hillary hunter at rspb org UK
shoplet hall equestrian center in chakla
road ss4 1lt run a fun Club on the
fourth eleventh thirteenth of April from
9am to 1pm this is a great chance for
five to ten year olds to learn all about
ponies with quizzes team games and a
pony ride and the cost is twenty pound
contact 0170 254 double three double
seven or visit info at shopping haul co
uk Rochford tennis club have an open day
at the premises at church warp Rochford
SS for one NL on saturday the 14th of
april from 9am to six pm it's free to
all from three years of age and upwards
there's tennis lessons fun tennis games
and an intro to cardiac tennis at 2pm
the contact details are 079 4724 1976
visit the website w WR OTE tennis coach
UK or email info at Rochford tennis
coach UK equipage scuba diving is that
greasewood academy pool in hockley every
wednesday evening from 730 p.m. so why
not come and try scuba diving for more
details call 0 1 702
3953 95 or email JP at aqua pigs co uk
you can help shape the future of
Southend University Hospital by becoming
a member of the hospital foundation
trust by becoming a member you may also
be able to stand for election as a
governor elections to the Board of
Governors will take place during May the
seats to be taken up in June available
governor seats in Rockford our patient
governor one seat public governor two
seats election packs for prospective
candidates will be available from the
end of March 2012 membership of the
trust is free and brings many benefits
for more information call free on the
800 0 1 8520 to or email foundation drop
members at Southend NHS UK the roach art
group meet Wednesday evenings between 7
30 and 9 30 p.m. at San Theresa's church
hall ashington Road Rochford and it's
located to the rear of the church
beginners are especially welcome but all
abilities are catered for at this
friendly club who work in a variety of
media as a venue with good lighting of
facilities reasonable fees apply and
details are on request so-called
Christine on 0170 2586 double 36 or John
on 079 double 326 3930 rayleigh Age
Concern meet five days a week 52 weeks a
year between ten-thirty a.m. & 2pm at
the Taubman center in Castle Road Railly
Railly 8 concern is eager for more older
people to attend and enjoy its daily
luncheon club home cooked fresh food
made on the premises is provided and
transport to and from the venue can also
be arranged for a moderate cost
entertainment as social events are
regularly arranged so contact 01 268
double 75 380
essex dementia care at the oasis
activity center raelia baptist church
high road ss6 7qa and they meet every
wednesday from 11am to 330 p.m. they
provide an active in a stimulating
environment for people living with
dementia and their carers so for more
information and book to book contact 0 1
2 4 5 36 37 89 you can email info at
essex dementia care UK or visit their
website wwx dementia care UK and please
note that although events are checked
before going to press they are subject
to change we recommend you visit our
website at www k or contact the
organizers to check before going to an
event
council committee and forum dates all
these meetings are held in the Civic
sweet to hot p road rail e SS 680 be
licensing committee is on the second of
april at ten in the morning executive
fourth of april 730 p.m. review
committee the eleventh of april 730 p.m.
it's committee twelve of april at
seven-thirty council meeting seventeenth
of april at seven-thirty development
committee 19th of april at seven-thirty
p.m. for further information contact
member services on 0 1 702 318 140 the
shop at my local campaign is going from
strength to strength with more than 420
businesses and 750 shoppers now signed
up all members now receive a weekly
email straight into the inbox with
discounts for local shops and businesses
helping you save money while supporting
local trade with 9 office in the first
week of January alone there has never
been a better site time to sign up and
save yourself money and the best thing
is is completely free to use shop at my
local has now got its own facebook page
and twitter feed simply search from shop
at my local on facebook and gain access
to news discounts information and events
in your local area shop at my local can
also be found on twitter at wwe.com
forward slash shop at my local both the
facebook page and twitter feed are
updated regularly so follow us to keep
up with to date with news discounts and
events in your local area
are you planning a jubilee street party
this summer 2012 will be an historic
year with a long weekend of celebrations
to mark the Queen's Diamond Jubilee in
early June including the big Jubilee
lunch on Sunday the third of June the
demand for street parties will be high
so we want to make it easier for you to
hold one without having to plow through
mountains of forms or face
disproportionate charges this guide
tells you how to apply to close your
street for a party what sort of events
does apply to the main features of a
small street party are these for
residents or neighbors only publicity
only to residents in a quiet residential
road or street self-organized normally
no insurance no formal risk assessment
needed no not licenses are normally
necessary if music is incidental and no
selling is involved it's that simple
organizing small private street parties
is very simple and generally doesn't
include activities that need a licence
such as selling alcohol or providing
certain types of entertainment the
number one tip for holding a party is to
plan early by getting in touch with us
at least four to six weeks in advance
more helpful tips advice and support for
organizing a successful event can be
found on the streets alive website www
street party org UK and the big lunch
website www and com and what happens
next well if you'd like to arrange a
street party for the Queen's Diamond
Jubilee you'll need to complete an
application form giving us as much
information as possible to enable us to
make a decision you can visit whr govt
UK to download a form or you can call
0170 2318 169 once you've completed a
form and sent it to us we'll look at
what you're proposing
your application for road closure and
let you know if there's anything else
you need to consider we hope this
guidance makes things easier for you and
good luck with your event elections are
now set to take place one-third of the
district council is up for re-election
as well as the town parish councils of
hotly hullbridge and rayleigh if you are
unable to go to the polling station on
Election Day you can apply for a postal
or proxy vote the closing date for new
postal votes or changes to existing
postal or proxy arrangements for these
elections is 5 p.m. on the 18th of April
the closing date for new proxy voting
applications is 5 p.m. on the
twenty-fifth of April application forms
can be downloaded from the council's
website w WH for govt UK or you can
contact the election of his helpline by
calling 0170 2318 187 or email elections
at Rochford dark UK the district walls
involved in this year's elections are
ashington and kenyan foul nest and great
wakering hockley central hockley north
hot key west hullbridge rayleigh central
lodge swing park trinity Rochford
Wheatley and white house and registering
to vote gives you a chance to elect your
local council representatives and have
your say about how your district is run
voting is your opportunity to make a
difference to the issues that are
important to you and the community for
more information on the elections you
can visit w WH foods co uk forward slash
elections don't forget to vote by
signing up to our free service the
election alarm clock the election alarm
clock is a convenient way to keep up to
date with all the information regarding
upcoming elections by signing up to the
electronic alarm clock you will be
alerted to upcoming elections when and
how to register for election
when and how you can vote and where you
can vote to sign up for this service
visit w WH foods co uk /a lection alarm
clock fill in your details are requested
and click Submit that's it once you have
done this you will start to receive
election alerts did you know this lots
more information on the website just
visit w WR govt UK for with / elections
to find out the current composition of
Rochford district council how to become
a counselor how you can register to vote
application forms for proxy and postal
voting past election results and on
election night the website will be
updated with all the results from the
local elections so don't forget
elections are on the third of May you
need to be registered to vote in UK
elections the deadline for registering
for the elections is the 18th of April
find out more by visiting w WH foods
guru K 4 with / elections don't be foul
clean up dog fouling it's a dirty
subject but one that affects us all
whether you own a dog or not at some
time or other most of us have
accidentally trodden in dogs mess and
been left with the unpleasant task of
cleaning it off our shoes or boots in
recent months the council's street scene
and open spaces officers have seen an
increase in the amount of drugs mess
that draw owners have failed to clean up
on the pavements parks and open spaces
in the district every dog owner should
be aware of their responsibility to
clean up after their dog immediately and
dispose of the waste appropriately by
placing it in one of the many dog waste
bins or by taking it home and placing it
in their non recycling bin under the
council's dog control orders that came
into force in 2008 anyone who's in
charge of a dog and fails to clean up
after that dog in public areas may be
prosecuted and if found guilty can be
lined up to 1,000 pounds under these
orders it's no excuse that you are
unaware that your dog has fouled or you
don't have any means to clean up after
the dog you can still be prosecuted the
council is committed to keeping our
district a clean and pleasant place for
residents and visitors alike and will
continue to clean up after irresponsible
dog owners walkers however we will also
visit areas where there is a particular
problem in an effort to deal with
individuals who are not clearing up
after their dogs for more information
about roxford District Council's Dog
Control orders and responsible dog
ownership please visit the council's
website rochford WK or contact sus
customer services on 0 1 702 3181 double
one thanks for the top spot the council
is so proud of all the efforts you've
made to make sure the district is the
top recycling Authority in the country
with a recycling rate last year of 65.7
9% the council topped the table above
every other local authority in England
the recycling team would like to say a
massive thank you to everyone who has
helped by recycling as much as possible
the team also want to help you so we can
try and stay top of the league and
maintain our position as the best
recycling Authority in the country for
as long as possible Rochford's recycling
team are always on how to provide advice
and information about which items can be
recycled and composted not only the bins
provided to households but also in the
recycling banks located around the
district including the new banking back
lane Rochford for small electrical items
such as kettles and toasters in addition
essex textiles work in partnership with
the council to provide a textiles shoes
and books collection from the curbside
on recycling collection day they also
provide a call and collect service so
you can arrange a specific date and time
for a collection so to get in touch cool
017
Oh 2318 treble one email customer
services at Rochford co uk or visit the
website w WH foods guru K and you can
contact Essex textiles oh-eight-hundred
787 9071 you can email them at info at
Essex textiles co uk or visit their
website WWE Essex textiles co uk easter
is nearly here and many of us will be
purchasing cards and easter eggs to
celebrate in fact each year
approximately 80 million easter eggs are
eaten in the UK however along with all
that chocolate comes enormous amounts of
cardboard plastic and foil packaging in
the Rockford district the cardboard foil
and molded plastic packaging can be
recycled at the curbside in your
recyclables bin however there are other
ways you can reduce the amount of
packaging you throw away one way you can
do this is to try making your own Easter
eggs children will have lots of fun
while saving money and helping the
environment Easter Egg molds can be
purchased at cooking shops or online and
although they may be made from plastic
they can be used over and over again if
you do make your own Easter eggs why not
email us a picture of how they turn out
we'll put pictures of your Easter Egg
creations on our recycle for Rochford
Facebook page send your entries to
communications at Rochford gov qk
watch that score strategy the plan for
the future development of the district
was adopted by the Council on 32
December 2011 following approval from
the government's planning inspector the
plan is the key planning document for
the entire district it sets out how the
area will develop over the next 15 years
addressing issues such as housing
employment town centre enhancements and
the environment to name but a few the
poor strategy was prepared over a number
of years involving evidence gathering
community involvement and analysis
before being submitted to the government
for examination in January 2010 at this
point an inspector was appointed by the
Secretary of State to determine if the
strategy was sound as part of the
examination hearing sessions were held
where objectors to policies had the
opportunity to explain their concerns to
the inspector following this process the
core strategy has not only been found
sound and legally compliant by the
inspector but only minor changes are
required the inspector found in favor of
the council on all significant issues
examples are some of the outcomes of
this include housing to meet our
districts requirement will be built in
the areas the council had suggested and
determined to be the most appropriate
following analysis and community
involvement the vast majority
approximately ninety nine percent of the
greenbelt will be protected from
development as will important
environmental areas and open spaces all
new homes will be built to the lifetime
home standard ensuring that new homes
can be adapted to meet our residents
needs whatever their circumstances you
development will be required to be built
to high environmental standards
developers will be required to include
affordable housing within their housing
development schemes and to incorporate
other requirements proposed by the
council including new schools in certain
locations play spaces used in community
facilities transport in provement six
new employment development will take
place north of london southend airport
west of rayleigh and in town centres
protection at varying historic
environment and character of our
district including buildings that may
not be nationally significant borough
but our of local importance so the legal
challenge to adoption of the poor
strategy and as section 113 of the
planning and compulsory purchase act of
2004 any person aggrieved by the core
strategy may make an application to the
High Court on grounds that the document
is not within the appropriate powers and
or a procedural requirement has not been
complied with the deadline for such an
application in respect of the Rochford
district course strategy was the 24th of
January 2012 on the 19th of January 2012
rochford district outs received
notification of a legal challenge to the
core strategy the legal challenge has
been bought by a cogent land LLP who are
seeking to quash certain policies namely
h1 h2 h3 and paragraphs 4.12 4.31 in the
core of strategy which relate to housing
the rest of the core strategy is
unaffected by this challenge at the time
of this publication the challenge
remains undetermined until the
challenged is determined the whole of
the core strategy has fully fit as
adopted the full core strategy document
is available to download from our
website simply visit w WR OTE UK and
click on pause strategy update in the
infocus bulbs
pause for thought with pets in the event
of an evacuation the council has a
number of rest centers available for
people however they can't accommodate
animals if there is an emergency and you
leave your pets at home we would advise
it to shut them inside an upstairs room
with ample supplies of food and water
leave notices on external doors saying
there are animals inside if animals are
left in a field or field shelter leave
your mergency contact details on the
gate and shelter if your pets are
evacuated emergency supplies are
essential this kit should be easily
assembled of short notice and able to be
stored in a sturdy container that's
easily carried and accessible the kit
could contain food seven days supply
minimum feeding bowls medication pet
carrier cage or great chain lead blanket
or pet coats treats toys and bedding
pooper scooper litter tray and litter a
picture of your pet with your
registration insurance microchip number
and vaccination documents in a sealed
waterproof bag for more information on
what else you can do to help your pets
in an emergency visit www.flu.gov UK
and now an NHS campaign let's be clear
about bowel cancer bowel cancer is the
second most common cancer in the UK and
when it comes to cancer deaths it's the
second biggest killer NHS South Essex is
supporting an important national cancer
awareness campaign to highlight the
early signs and symptoms of bowel cancer
the be clear clear on cancer campaign
aims to increase cancer survival rates
through early detection bowel cancer
affects both men and women most people
diagnosed with the disease are over 50
and those with a family history of bowel
cancer are more at risk people are being
encouraged to seek advice and treatment
if they believe they may have the
symptoms of bowel cancer the earlier
symptoms are checked with the GP the
better the chance of successful
treatment and survival so how to spot it
if for the last three weeks has there
been blood in your poo as your poo bin
loser if you have experienced one of
these symptoms in the last three weeks
you should visit your GP other signs and
symptoms can include persistent change
in bowel habits bleeding from back
passage pain discomfort in the abdomen a
lump in your abdomen losing weight for
no obvious reason bowel problems are
quite common it doesn't necessarily mean
you have bowel cancer if you experience
these symptoms there could be symptoms
of other conditions such as hemorrhoids
or piles however you should not try to
diagnose yourself you should visit your
GP and if it isn't serious your mind
will be put at rest if is a serial
serious conditions such as bowel cancer
the earlier its diagnose the more
treatable it is this eating visiting
your GP could save your life for more
information about bowel cancer symptoms
please contact your GP practice or visit
w wh s UK /bo cancer
staying safe on a night out the Rochford
District Community Safety Partnership
CSP has unveiled two initiatives aimed
at encouraging young people to take
their personal safety more seriously
working with Rochford district youth
council the CSP has published stays safe
a handy personal safety guide for young
people 5,000 copies are being
distributed through the youth council
Rochford District Council the CSP and
police and fire local pubs and clubs the
pocket-sized leaflet contains the useful
tips on keeping safe when out and about
ranging from what to avoid when going
clubbing to being street smart if
troweling alone rochford district
council's domestic abuse reduction
advisor Tracey Schneider said the idea
came about as a result of feedback from
my talks in schools and work with adults
common sense can go out the window when
people are partying regardless of age
and it was evident young people wanted
more advice on keeping safe without
having a good time in a separate move
the partnership has enlisted selected
local pubs and clubs to distribute a few
key items to help safeguard female
customers including a personal safety
alarm bottle of mineral water and a pair
of one size flip flops together with a
drawstring bag tracy said it's easy to
get caught up in the excitement of a
night out dancing without giving a
thought what happens when the music
stops and each item has been included to
help clubbers get home safely
distribution of the items has been
clearly targeted to have the most impact
the chair of the CSP and Rochford
District Council's portfolio holder for
young persons and community safety
counselor do McPherson said I welcome
the emission initiative shown by the CSP
and the Youth Council in producing this
guide to help fill a demonstrable
knowledge gap and also commend those
local clubs and pubs who have agreed to
distribute the bags to revelers it shows
a real concern for the safety of their
patrons once they've left the premises
Andrew and Nicola farmer from Rockford
were among 44 cyclists who took the
opportunity to have their bicycles
fitted with security tags and a special
tagging session held by neighborhood
watch the couple read about the event
which was held at raley library in
Rockford district matters and decided to
take advantage of the free fitting
service sponsored by this C SP Andrew
said we thought he'd a good idea and the
fitting took only a matter of minutes
vikes fitted with the electronic chips a
proven deterrent to bike thieves are
more likely to be returned to their
owners should they be recovered after
being stolen or lost the implants are
inserted into the frame of the bike and
each contains its own unique code which
is registered on a national database
with details of that particular bike and
its true owner there are lots of by
tagging events coming up and don't
forget to keep checking the website
which is updated with new events at www
k /r DM dog lovers bike owners and
anyone who's concerned about their local
parks and open spaces have the
opportunity to make their views known
the CSP has organized an event over the
next couple of months which you are
welcome to attend and the next one is
due to take place at the Boston Avenue
play space in rayleigh on friday the
20th of april between two and four p.m.
similar events have already taken place
a great wakering recreational ground and
at Cherry Orchard Country Park the
events have been organized so you can
raise your concerns and
discuss issues such as fly-tipping
littering dog fouling illegal
motorcycling and other acts of
anti-social behavior that spoil the
enjoyment of other park users as well as
this dog owners will have the
opportunity to have their pet fitted
with a free microchip and the details
registered on a national database
courtesy of the dogs trust to aid its
return should it ever go astray
Neighborhood Watch will be on hand to
fit free security devices to bicycles to
deter their theft and the Rayleigh
Rochford and district association for
voluntary service or rafts will be at
both events to promote volunteering
opportunities Essex Faro Rescue Service
Essex Police and Essex County Council
will also have a presence at each
location to provide information and deal
with inquiries from the public we look
forward to seeing you there rochford
district matters is edited by patrick
john and produce by rockford district
council who can be found at three to
nineteen south street rockford SS 41 VW
their name telephone number is zero one
seven zero to five four six three six
six and their website is at www Rockford
gavotte UK the paper is printed by
Charmin and company limited that brings
us to the end of this edition which was
recorded by volunteers from the rayleigh
Rochford and castle point talking
newspapers for the blind at their studio
in rockford